all right the American Embassy in Turkey
was shot at overnight at a time when
tensions are rising between turkey in
the u.s. local police are looking for
the suspects who opened fire early this
morning in the capital of Ankara the
Embassy was closed at the time of the
attack a spokesman for Turkey's
president says the gunmen wanted to
create chaos Holly Williams is an
Istanbul following the investigation
Holly good morning good morning the
authorities in Ankara say six rounds
were fired at the US Embassy at 5:30
this morning local time
from a white vehicle this is certainly
not the first time that a US diplomatic
mission here in Turkey has come under
attack in 2013 the Embassy was targeted
by a suicide bomber killing a security
guard and in 2015 attackers opened fire
outside the US consulate here in
Istanbul but this attack comes as
relations between the u.s. and Turkey to
NATO allies are strained perhaps even to
breaking point they are at odds over
several issues including pasta Andrew
Brunson an evangelical pastor from North
Carolina who Turkey accuses of spying
and terrorism and who's been in
detention here for nearly two years in
response the u.s. imposed sanctions this
month and both sides have imposed
announced tariffs on some goods Turkey's
president rejected Iran has called this
an economic war but we do not know if or
how this shooting was connected with
those tensions John Holly Williams in
Turkey thanks